-Mon invité est plutôt
du genre précoce.
Il a été élu conseiller municipal
à l'âge de 19 ans,
premier adjoint au maire à 27
et il s'est retiré
de la politique à 32.
L'histoire aurait pu s'arrêter là,
mais il a replongé
pour devenir député.
Générique
...
Bonjour, Stéphane Viry.
-Bonjour.
-En 1989,
vous avez été le plus jeune
conseiller municipal
de France élu
dans l'équipe
de Philippe Séguin à Epinal
et vous avez découvert
ce qu'est la vie d'un élu local.
On a trouvé votre témoignage
recueilli en 1992.
Vous aviez 22 ans.
Témoignage recueilli
par Image Plus.
*-Je m'étais pas fait à l'idée
d'être l'assistante sociale
d'un quartier d'Epinal.
*On vient nous solliciter
parce que le fossé
*n'a pas été curé, parce que
le ramassage des ordures ménagères
*a été fait une heure après.
*Je n'avais pas ce souci,
le ramassage
*des ordures ménagères
ou le souci des papiers
qui traînent dans la rue.
Ce n'était pas ce qui m'intéressait
le plus dans une activité
*municipale,
même si c'est important.
-Vous aviez un peu idéalisé
le fait d'être
un homme politique local
et vous avez découvert une réalité
un peu différente.
-Oui.
C'était une découverte.
Mon engagement
est le fait du hasard,
c'était pas programmé.
Une proposition en 1989
d'être sur la liste d'un homme
que j'admirais en tant que maire.
Je rejoins son équipe, je suis élu,
alors que c'était pas prévu.
En effet, on idéalise l'action,
la façon d'être positif,
de construire des projets.
On s'aperçoit que l'attente
citoyenne est un peu différente,
mais ça a été une belle école,
je ne regrette rien.
Je crois que ça a construit
ma personnalité, mon parcours.
-Ce côté assistante sociale
que vous évoquez,
il existe aussi,
quand on est député ?
Ca fait partie
du job ?
-En effet,
dans l'imagerie populaire,
ça fait partie de la fonction,
mais pas statutairement.
Le député vote la loi,
contrôle l'action du gouvernement
et défend un territoire,
mais on est très sollicités
par des citoyens
qui viennent demander
qu'on accélère un dossier,
qu'on rétablisse des droits,
qu'on les écoute.
Ca fait partie de la fonction.
J'apprécie d'être au contact,
sonder, me faire engueuler.
-C'est aussi un moyen
de vous sentir utile ?
-Oui, et puis aussi d'apaiser.
On est souvent le dernier recours,
la dernière oreille.
On apporte parfois la solution.
Pas toujours,
on a pas tout le pouvoir.
Parfois, des citoyens viennent
nous voir pour un passe-droit.
Là, c'est plus difficile.
C'est pas parce qu'on est député
qu'on doit contourner la loi
pour obtenir des faveurs.
Mais notre fonction
est de chercher à apaiser,
à expliquer, à faire en sorte
qu'on se sente mieux
dans ce collectif.
-Dernier détail,
mais ça m'a marqué.
Quand vous parlez,
vous avez 22 ans.
On a l'impression
que vous en avez 35.
Vous avez toujours été comme ça ?
-Je sais pas, peut-être
que la caméra me faisait
être un peu sérieux.
Au début de la vie,
on se sent investi
d'une mission qu'on n'a pas.
Non, je pense pas avoir été...
En tout cas, ça a accéléré ma vie.
Lorsqu'on est élu aux côtés
d'un mec comme Séguin,
il te façonne, il te façonne
dans ta façon de te construire,
de regarder la France.
J'ai peut-être été plus exigeant
sur moi, sur des choses...
Je sais pas, je pourrais pas
vous dire précisément.
-On va parler de Philippe Séguin.
Vous l'avez dit,
il a joué un rôle clé
dans votre engagement.
Vous l'avez évoqué d'un mot,
mais comment ça s'est fait ?
Comment vous vous êtes retrouvé
sur cette liste ?
-Je vais être cavalier...
Un casting.
A l'époque, l'idée, c'est d'avoir
un ou deux jeunes sur sa liste.
J'avais été membre
du Conseil des jeunes
d'Epinal, j'avais fait
des actions sympas,
je m'étais fait repérer.
Quelques semaines
avant les élections,
on te propose de rejoindre l'équipe,
t'es dans une position inéligible,
en fin de liste.
Séguin ayant été un bon maire,
il a été plébiscité
et je me suis retrouvé embarqué
dans cette très belle aventure
et j'ai appris,
j'ai découvert.
J'avais 19 ans.
D'être plongé dans un monde,
effectivement, d'adultes,
c'est compliqué, à 19 ans,
alors que t'es étudiant,
que t'as envie d'être
avec tes potes.
-Vous avez poursuivi vos études.
-Oui, en parallèle,
mais tu te retrouves
dans des commissions.
-Sur les finances publiques.
-M. Séguin
m'avait demandé
d'être rapporteur
à 19 ans, donc tu te mets
dans des bouquins inimaginables.
A l'époque, je gérais
l'argent de poche de mes parents.
Donc, ça a été des moments
forts et qui m'ont construit,
et de belles rencontres.
-"Il m'a façonné sans le dire."
Qu'est-ce qu'il a façonné ?
Qu'avez-vous gardé de lui
dans sa façon de faire
de la politique ?
-Je l'ai lu, écouté, observé.
J'ai eu des moments privilégiés,
probablement, avec lui,
pendant des années,
des apartés comme ceux-là.
Il était assez puissant,
au niveau de la France,
il a contribué à l'élection
de Jacques Chirac.
Il avait une vision du pays,
de la République,
de l'égalité des chances,
de la cohésion sociale.
Quand je raisonne en politique
par rapport à des choix,
qui sont parfois compliqués,
j'ai cet ADN.
-En 1995, il a fait de vous
son adjoint aux finances
et deux ans plus tard,
il a quitté Epinal pour se consacrer
à sa carrière politique nationale,
prenant la tête du RPR
et se projetant
aux municipales de Paris.
En quittant Epinal,
il vous a proposé de prendre
sa succession à la mairie ?
-Ca a été évoqué,
mais c'était pas ma place.
J'avais l'idée de vivre autrement
que par la vie politique.
Il y avait à l'époque
Michel Heinrich,
un bon premier adjoint.
Il fallait respecter
l'ordre des choses.
Je peux vivre sans politique.
Je ne suis pas addict
à la politique.
Je ne regrette pas ces premières
parties de ma vie professionnelle
que j'ai dévolues
à cette action pour Epinal.
Je n'avais pas l'idée
de faire ça toute ma vie.
-Après le départ de M. Séguin,
vous êtes l'adjoint de M. Heinrich.
A 2001, à l'âge où certains
entrent en politique,
vous, vous la quittez.
Pourquoi ?
-Parce que...
Je voulais être autonome
et ne pas dépendre
de la vie politique.
La vie politique est une mission.
Tu as un mandat pour exercer
un certain temps.
Moi, je dis que politique,
ce n'est pas une profession.
C'est quelque chose que tu accomplis
parce que tu as été candidat
et que tu as été élu.
Je voulais pas être dépendant de ça.
J'avais fait des études de droit,
je voulais m'installer,
exercer la profession d'avocat,
je ne voulais pas faire
les deux choses en même temps.
Je me suis donc retiré
de la vie politique.
-Vous n'aviez pas aussi
perdu la flamme ?
Je cite :
"Je n'ai plus la motivation
"me permettant de contracter
un engagement pour 6 ans."
-Je crois que c'est normal.
Je pourrais vous dire la même chose
avec la fonction que j'exerce.
-Vous n'avez plus la flamme ?
-Si.
On a l'enthousiasme, la hargne
d'aller chercher des choses,
d'aller prendre ce qu'on peut
pour les citoyens.
Après, ce sont
des fonctions astreignantes,
parfois douloureuses,
parfois frustrantes,
il faut avoir toujours
au fond de soi
cette volonté,
cette capacité physique, psychique,
à aller chercher quelque chose.
Je m'étais engagé à 19 ans,
j'en avais 31.
12 ans, à cet âge-là.
-C'était la fin d'un cycle ?
-J'aspirais à autre chose.
-Cette autre chose a pris la forme,
6 ans plus tard,
d'une autre forme d'engagement
en tant que président du club
de foot d'Epinal,
que vous avez fait passer de CFA 2
en National.
Vous voyez des points communs
entre la politique
et l'engagement associatif ?
-Oui.
C'est pour moi la même chose,
tu donnes de ton temps
pour une cause commune.
Quand tu t'engages
dans une association,
que ce soit une amicale de parents,
un comité des fêtes,
un comité d'entreprise
ou toute autre association,
tu ne le fais pas pour toi,
tu le fais pour autrui.
Dans la politique, tu le fais
par rapport à un mandat.
Dans une association,
à un moment, on te propose
de porter un club associatif,
tu prends le projet,
tu le crées et tu essayes
d'embarquer des bénévoles,
des forces vives, qui ont
peut-être la même idée que toi
de faire avancer les choses.
La politique, c'est la même chose.
-Vous y avez vécu
les meilleurs moments de votre vie.
-Je le confirme.
-Vous y avez trouvé des choses
que la politique
ne vous donnait pas ?
-La simplicité, peut-être...
De la générosité humaine.
Le club de foot d'Epinal,
c'est une belle histoire.
Je parle pas des résultats.
On se retrouve avec des bénévoles,
dans un comité
directeur.
On est tous différents,
mais on a cette idée
de bosser pour ce club.
Il y a des moments de doute,
des nuits blanches.
"Comment je vais gérer ça ?"
Il y a des contraintes,
un minibus pour les gamins,
mais ça, au fond de moi,
j'ai trouvé un épanouissement
très profond et sincère.
Si j'ai une sensation qui me manque,
c'est bien celle-ci.
-Vous vous êtes engagé dans
la fondation Agir pour l'exclusion
et dans l'association
Jeunesse et culture,
qui fait de la prévention.
Finalement, ce n'est là
que vous êtes heureux ?
Dans ce côté qu'on évoquait
au début de l'émission
d'assistant social ?
-Oui. J'aime ça.
Vous savez, on a tous une vocation.
Moi, j'aime le collectif,
j'aime avancer des idées,
j'aime chercher à trouver
des solutions, mais pas pour moi,
pour des causes, pour des objectifs,
pour des utopies, parfois.
-Vous êtes revenu en politique
en 2014 aux côtés
du député-maire d'Epinal,
Michel Heinrich.
Dans la perspective du non-cumul
des mandats,
il devait laisser un mandat
de maire ou de député
et il vous a proposé,
pas de choisir, mais de décider
où vous tenteriez votre chance.
Vous avez choisi les législatives
pour devenir député. Pourquoi ?
-C'est l'histoire
de France, la constituante,
c'est le droit.
En étant avocat,
j'ai peut-être ce réflexe,
mais sans aucun doute,
ce sont les législatives.
On s'inscrit dans l'idée qu'à terme,
car je rentre en 2014,
à terme, pour 2017,
je puisse potentiellement
obtenir une investiture.
C'était l'idée de voir
où on allait aller,
et on est allés
à l'investiture en 2017.
-C'est l'heure du quiz.
Je vous explique le principe.
Je vous propose de compléter
des phrases qui sont en lien
avec votre histoire,
votre parcours.
On y va ?
"Si Philippe Séguin était encore
président de l'Assemblée..."
-Il serait devenu
président de la République.
-Je pensais que vous parleriez
des débats
dans l'hémicycle agité,
comment ça serait.
-Il serait malheureux,
car il aimait beaucoup
cette institution.
Il serait un chouïa plus autoritaire
que la présidente actuelle.
"Jouer au foot aux côtés de députés
"LFI ou RN..."
-Aucun problème.
-Vous jouez au foot
avec les parlementaires.
-Oui.
Je continue à jouer à côté d'Epinal,
c'est un moment de rayonnement.
On n'a pas d'identité,
pas de fonction,
pas d'âge, on partage un truc.
J'aime cette fraternité,
j'aime ce sport.
Qu'on porte un maillot,
mes collègues LFI ou RN
ont été élus
par le suffrage universel.
Je ne vais pas les distinguer.
J'avais invité
à Epinal François Ruffin
à venir faire un match
avec mon équipe de vétérans.
Le sport, c'est autre chose.
Il faut respecter les fondamentaux.
-"Etre député,
"c'est renoncer à..."
-A une partie de soi.
C'est...
C'est compliqué.
-C'est compliqué ?
-Voilà.
Non, mais...
Il faut mesurer les conséquences
que ça peut avoir
pour tes proches, pour tes enfants.
Etre député,
c'est renoncer à tout le reste.
-Il n'y aura pas
de troisième mandat ?
-Je m'inscris pas dans la durée,
j'ai pas l'idée de finir ma carrière
dans une action politique,
je l'ai toujours dit.
J'ai l'idée de proposer
autre chose,
une autre contribution.
-Vous savez pas encore quoi.
-Nous verrons bien.
-Merci beaucoup,
Stéphane Viry, d'être venu.
-Merci à vous.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
Générique
...